[Music]
foreign
Joel Baker I run American Giants what we
do is find and restore old 1960s
International fiberglass Giants I'm
going to walk you through how my team
restores a muffler man in this case a
Paul Bunyan Muffler Men were large
20-foot advertising Giants that were
made in the early 60s by the
international fiberglass company these
guys were really made to bring attention
to your business so business owners love
to buy them set them up outside and it
would get the family car to pull over on
a road trip this particular Muffler Man
is buried in the back of an old
Campground in Wisconsin that had gone
out of business we're guessing he's
around a 1964 model which would make him
kind of one of the early ones made
[Music]
when I first discovered this guy and got
a good look at him I realized he had
fallen over when they fall forward they
land on their hands and that had pushed
his shoulders out and cracked them
our guys hold the shoulder in place
while another guy will screw small
boards all around the crack to hold it
in place and when we're happy with that
fit then we screw it in and the next
step is we go into fiberglass filler
once the boards are holding the shoulder
in place for this particular crack then
we can go on the inside of the Giant and
we can lay down fresh fiberglass and
basically connect that shoulder piece
back to the rest of the Giant
this bunion head had a lot of detail in
the beard so we basically take Bondo and
fiberglass resin and we put it into all
those seams of the beard
once all the cracks on the giant are
fixed and all the holes are patched it's
really the hardest part of the job and
this is sanding we use orbital sanders
to sand the Giant and we go over every
square inch of the Giant and remove all
those layers of paint that had added up
over the years
once all the fiberglass repair has been
done then it's time for the first coat
of primer and we'd use a filler primer
that's thick and it can seep into all
these little pinholes and cracks and
fill them as best it can
the primer is sprayed onto the whole
Giant
simultaneously while all this priming is
going on we are also working on the feet
the major thing wrong with this guy was
he was missing his feet and this is very
common we see this a lot when you have a
business that has a muffler man and then
they want to get rid of them instead of
unbolting the feet they cut the feet off
at the ankles we have made molds of the
correct feet from other Giants we had to
make new boots
then we find a point on the original
Giant's leg that we can cut and we
basically cut about a foot off of the
original leg at a good mating point for
the new boot we get a good lineup on the
boot into the original leg and then we
use wood and screws to basically bolt
that on and hold it in place once we're
happy with the position and the toes are
pointed in the right direction and
everything looks good then we're going
to go in and we're going to fiberglass
the inside of those legs
and then we'll come back and we'll
actually Prime that area again and make
sure it's a perfect fit and you would
never know that this guy has replacement
feet
in this case the buyer also wanted an ax
that was an original we didn't have an
original ax so we again used our molds
to make an identical ax to the original
axes once the ax is put together then we
go ahead and sand it down and prime it
in anything the Giants hold we always
drill holes in them that way if there
are any water leaks the water can drain
the next step is very tedious but it's
very important and it's called wet
sanding instead of using orbital sanders
we will use sandpaper by hand and we
will spray the giant down so it's all
wet and we'll use a very fine grit of
sandpaper to go over that second coat of
primer and this is basically getting rid
of anything in that primer paint That's
you can't even see but that is sticking
up and may make the final paint job look
not quite as smooth
foreign
once the wet sanding is complete and
everything looks good to us it's an
exciting time because we need to send
all of our pieces a few miles away to a
paint shop once at the paint shop the
painter is going to talk to us about
what colors we want for this giant it's
very important that the buyer picks out
what colors that they want we often will
recommend that they go with the original
colors since we like everything to be
original but it's really up to the buyer
and what paint job they want the first
thing the painter will do is to put on
the base coats on the shoes the legs the
shirt and the head and these are all
solid colors that go on each parts we
always use automotive Quality Paint to
give us a five to seven year life before
you see any signs of deterioration
once the base coats are on the giant
then it's time for the details and this
is when the painter will go to work with
an airbrush and do all the fine details
of highlighting the hair adding skin
tones the painter will also take great
care in doing the eyes and adding a lot
of eye details in the pupils
[Music]
once all the airbrush details are
complete then it is time for a clear
coat and this gives it a really nice
glossy shine and this clear coat also
protects the giant for the long term
from Sun and weather and being in the
elements
[Music]
foreign
start coming back to the shop fully
painted it's the time to really
concentrate on the internal structure of
the giant a lot of the buyers want the
giant to freestand in heavy heavy wind
the first thing we do is we do a
cardboard cutout of the Giant's
footprint and then we take that
cardboard cutout to a machine shop and
they make us a print of that foot that's
made out of a quarter inch steel then we
can weld on four inch pipes onto that
and those pipes will go up the leg once
the pipes reach the waist we weld in
Cross bracing that connects to the waste
it's during the process of installing
the internal structure that we also Bolt
the giant together we do a final fit of
the waste and the Torso and we also bolt
on the head at this time
a date is agreed on with the buyer of
the Giant and before we get there a slab
has been poured at that location once
the giant is unwrapped on site it's time
to install anything that he needs to
hold in his hands with this bunion he
held an ax so we made sure that all the
bolts that the ax were going to slide
onto were already in place so on site
it's pretty easy to just make sure the
fit is right and Bolt the ax down before
he's raised up
at this point a crane or a lift is
brought in to lift the Giant from the
trailer
we take time at this point to make sure
that the giant is orientated properly we
all have the new buyer come in and look
at the Giant and make sure they are a
hundred percent happy with the way the
giant is facing and when they are good
we gently set the giant down on the slab
and those foot plates that are under his
feet they have tabs in them and those
tabs have holes and we basically drill
through those holes into the slab once
all the holes have been drilled we will
insert concrete anchor bolts and once we
tighten those bolts up the bolts expand
underneath in the concrete and press
against the concrete therefore locking
the giant into place
[Music]
once the giant is standing we like to
take a step back and get some pictures
and really take the time to appreciate
all our hard work in bringing another
one of these Giants back to life these
Giants up to this point have lasted for
50 years and we really want to give them
another 50 years
and now this fully restored bunion
stands at Cumberland Ridge Forest
Products in Elkton Kentucky
[Music]
thank you